we will never stop talking about this it
was so shocking
that is the worst thing will smith has
ever done fallout from that oscars
shocker overnight will smith apologizing
on instagram for slapping chris rock
after he made that joke about jada
pinkett smith
unacceptable inexcusable and out of line
will issues an apology to his 61 million
followers on instagram following sunday
night's oscar showdown and explains what
set him off jokes at my expense are a
part of the job but a joke about jada's
medical condition was too much for me to
bear and i reacted emotionally then will
addresses chris head on i would like to
publicly apologize to you chris i was
out of line and i was wrong i'm
embarrassed and my actions were not
indicative of the man i want to be
apologizing to the academy again will
also includes the williams family in a
statement stating he deeply regrets his
behavior and is a work in progress chris
has yet to respond to sunday's incident
but we do know he has declined to file a
police report and according to diddy the
two have already made amends but this is
not stopping late night from taking aim
at will america may be divided but it
was
kind of nice for all of us to come
together and say holy crap at the same
time
kimmel throws it back to a time where he
hosted the oscars and now i'm a little
bummed because i've only now hosted the
second craziest oscars of all time
well stephen colbert offers a different
solution challenge chris to a duel or if
we really want to hurt a comedian don't
laugh
now that will has apologized what's next
the two have quite the history appearing
in several movies and tv shows together
chris even had an appearance in will's
hit show the fresh prince of bel air all
right i'll do the show
the comedian also starred alongside jada
in the 2005 animated film madagascar in
addition to the movie's two sequels as
for jada she's seemingly moving on
simply posting this photo to instagram
with the message this is a season for
healing and i'm here for it